you had a chance to uh do something fun
over the weekend yeah so we talked about
this uh on friday
where i was going to be the conductor of
the polar express i wasn't quite sure
how it was all going to work out yeah
but i have to tell you it was so much
fun so what did they do exactly how did
everybody ride the polar express well
take a look
after meeting with the elves and some of
the other train conductors
and as a choir from the las vegas
academy wrapped up their holiday carols
[Music]
it was time to fire up the polar express
engine
at the cleverly disguised simmer on rose
community center's sports courts on ann
road dear durango
the elves danced
hot chocolate was served
[Music]
kids and families danced and sang then
[Music]
the big man showed up
the kids snapped pictures with him
before we all went home
a simple night about an hour so long but
the kids had a ball and a special thanks
to erin clark from the cimarron rose
community center for inviting me uh the
tip of the conductors had also to the
small but mighty little engine that
could staff that work with energy
enthusiasm and camaraderie to bring joy
to hundreds of families with little kids
yeah that's so cool it was just an
imaginary polar express right without
having to go to the railroad tracks yeah
right for five dollars a person oh my
gosh that's really creative yeah you
really you own the conductor uh motif
thank you well the hat was great and i
didn't i didn't get a fake mustache
right you grew one on your own